on Sunday we're nearly at the end of
January and it feels to me like it's
getting towards crunch time for the
Prime Minister which is sunak originally
defined himself as all about fixing
problems and steadying the ship after
the chaos of last year but is that
enough if he's going to have a chance of
winning the next election so you need to
offer something a bit more exciting a
little bit less managerial rather than
just defining himself as more competent
than the conservatives who've gone
before we'll be exploring all the big
issues with our guests on the show this
morning in just a moment we'll hear from
the leveling up secretary Michael Gove
and for labor we'll be talking to the
party's Shadow education secretary
Bridget Phillipson we'll find out what
Andy Burnham the mayor of Greater
Manchester makes and what Michael Gove
has to say this morning and the
government's progress on leveling up so
far and following the Chancellor's call
for an end to declinism over the state
of the UK economy we'll be talking to
the director general of the British
Chambers of Commerce on the program as
well plus we are going to bring you you
an extraordinarily powerful interview
with Hannah Lewis who survives the
Holocaust but saw a Nazi death squad
kill her own mother
[Music]
well let's crack straight on shall we we
start this morning with the leveling up
secretary and it's more than five and a
half years since the grenful tower fire
that killed 72 people and Michael gave
this morning says the government is
partially to blame for the disaster
because of poor guidance on buildings I
spoke to Michael gave just a few moments
ago
thank you so much for being on the
program this morning I think it's quite
refreshing to actually start with policy
after the last few weeks but I did want
to talk to you about policy we all
remember the absolute tragedy of the
gramful fire six years on it feels like
you're finally doing something on unsafe
cladding what is the plan well we're
making clear to developers that we've
got a new contract that they've got to
sign so the people who were responsible
for erecting buildings which we now know
are unsafe have to pay the costs of
making sure that those buildings are
safe we've been trying to to deal with
this problem as you quite rightly say
for a number of years and they've been
well-intentioned efforts actually by
lots of people but the knob of it is
that until recently the leaseholders the
people actually in the flats were being
asked to consider paying for some of the
costs for things that they were not
responsible for so that should end now
that we're publishing this contract and
seeing developers and to be fair they
they accept the responsibility should
pay up Skies City editor Mark Kleinman
reported this one week that you're close
to signing this legally blinding deal to
fix unsafe buildings so when do you hope
it's going to be signed and how much
could it cost the industry well we're
going to publish it tomorrow and we are
going to give every developer sort of
Windows six weeks during which we hope
they will sign some have already
indicated that they will I mean I don't
want to preempt you know there's a bit
of a speculation about some of the
developers who will but all the
indications are uh that the overwhelming
majority will and those who don't will
face consequences if they don't sign the
contract uh we'll make sure that in
effect they won't be able to build
anything more in the future
um and uh yeah we we think it will be in
the in the realm of billions that we
will be able to unlock in order to deal
with this crisis in the region of five
billion is that right yes
um you know I just want to talk you say
that they've been well-intentioned
efforts before
the same time you know grenful happened
six years ago we all remember you know
that the horrific images of those people
trapped inside the building and only
seven percent of 368 000 dangerous Flats
have been fixed yes it's not good enough
I mean the intentions might be good but
that's that's not gonna happen no no I I
completely agree I'm I am the first I
hope to acknowledge that we haven't done
right by uh the the bereaved and the
residents and the survivors in grenfell
and that is one very very important
Mission but it's also the case that
there have been people who have been
effectively imprisoned in their own fats
for too long uh as we know after grenful
um there were hundreds of buildings that
were identified as having similar faults
to grenful not identical but similar
um and uh we knew that all of the people
who were in those buildings uh not only
were they not safe but it was also the
case entirely understandably that they
could move because they couldn't sell
their flat couldn't get a mortgage you
know from an economic point of view the
market was Frozen but from a human point
of view far more importantly people's
lives were were completely disrupted so
again
um I haven't always will apologized to
people for the fact that it's taken this
long to sort but now we have got
progress do you also take some
responsibility on behalf of the
government for what happened at
Granville I think that if you look at
what happened to Grenville there were
lots of factors but yes government
collectively has to take some
responsibility now I think that the
responsibility extends before the
conservatives came into government in in
um and I'm I'm not about attributing
blame to individuals I think that's
wrong because uh there are a lot of us
who have a responsibility to say that
the system of Regulation that was in
place was ambiguous and it was exploited
by people who were putting profit before
lives and and again you know there's
there is I think and I hope this doesn't
seem so on dodging responsibility I
don't want to at all I think there's a
difference between presiding over a
system that's negligent and actively
exploiting it but it is undeniably the
case that the system of building
regulation was not right would you
apologize to those families I absolutely
would and uh again I've had the uh the
chance to talk to many of the families
most directly affected since doing this
job I
um brought up my children just quite
close to uh to Granville and I remember
visiting aside just a couple of days
after the the fire and thinking that it
was horrific that this had happened the
more that I discovered about uh the
circumstances they're the more horrified
I was there were people in that building
who had warned beforehand uh that they
were in potential danger the warnings
were not heated
um and the inquiry which followed and uh
Theresa May was absolutely right to set
it up because it it's it's shown a light
on terrible practice it exposed the fact
that there were a variety of different
people from the people who manufactured
the cladding to the people who applied
it who just didn't do the right thing
and I have more question on housing
before we move on to other issues
someone who she always says has
experience of the peculiarities of the
leasehold system I was quite struck by
your interview with the Sunday Times
where you said you wanted to abolish it
yes are you hoping for that to happen
before the election yes we want to
introduce legislation in the the final
parliamentary session so later this
calendar year in order to change the
leasehold system it's not easy in legal
terms because you know when you've got a
tangle of property laws going back
hundreds of years unstitching all of
that is difficult but the fundamental
thing is that leasehold is just a it's
an unfair form of property ownership uh
you know in crude terms if you buy a
flat that should be yours you shouldn't
be on the hook for charges which uh
managing agents and other people can
land you with which are you know gouging
um another story that I'm Keen to find
out more about this morning is given the
state of the ambulance waiting times is
that tomorrow you're announcing a plan
to treat half a million patients in what
you're calling hospitals at home yeah
what's that idea well the the principle
there is to make sure that we can
provide people with the quality of care
that they might enjoy in hospital in
their home and there are at least three
benefits from that the first is that
there are many people I know personally
who would rather have a relative at home
uh if they're ill and if they can get
the care required and this comes to the
second point if you can make sure that
there are uh visits by nurses or by
other clinical professionals who can
make sure that someone is comfortable
and looked after effectively then the
third thing is that you can also free up
capacity in hospitals themselves for uh
the more acute cases that require more
specific intervention let's you know get
to the number of what this is right you
know hospitals at home
it's not really hospital it's your home
right that's it feels like a quite a
nice kind of way of putting it but
you're effectively being treated at home
because our hospitals are full yes the
average ambulance wait time for a heart
attack 93 minutes in December 55 000
people waiting on trolleys more than 12
hours in a e you're being forced to do
this and you have some nice phrase for
your hospitals at home because there
aren't enough beds well again one of the
reasons why we need to do it is that
there are people who are in hospital who
need care but who can be cared for
effectively at home um you know again in
hospitals we all know there are
intensive care units there are other
facilities that do require uh the the
individual to have the the the the range
of interventions that can only be
delivered in hospital but there are
other things that can be done uh there
are drugs that can be administered there
are treatments that can be monitored
um and provided someone is uh safe and
warm at home then that care can be
administered there and again uh when the
Prime Minister organized a health Summit
a few weeks ago uh one of the the
Striking things that uh that came out of
that and which many of us knew
beforehand was that if you can have the
the right bespoke package of care then
someone can be more comfortable and uh
easily as well cared for as a hospital
but it depends on the type of patient it
depends on the type of condition of
course
um let's talk about the other Sunday on
the front page of the Sunday Times at
shall we and this is the story about
Boris Johnson and his relationship with
Richard Sharp who is now of course the
BBC chairman and whether or not Richard
Sharp helped to guarantee or find
someone to guarantee an 800 000 pound
loan well according to the Sunday Times
Boris Johnson was formally told to stop
asking Mr Sharp advice about his Affairs
days before he was announced as a
government's choice for BBC chairman
this is the letter the advice from the
cabinet office according to the Sunday
Times given the imminent announcement of
Richard Sharp As the new BBC chair it's
important that you no longer ask his
advice about your personal financial
matters and I just want to compare that
to what Boris Johnson told Sky News last
week when he said worship sharp knows
absolutely nothing about my personal
finances I can tell you that for Ding
Dang at sure I mean how can that
possibly be true well I think again I
don't know about the conversations that
that we're carrying on
um what are the only two things I would
say the one thing is that I know that uh
and I've seen it happen in the past that
there are uh there's a letter here a
note there a comment there it points
towards one conclusion once you know all
the evidence actually another conclusion
can fairly be drawn though you know if
he was given a letter by the Simon Case
by the cabinet so secretary saying stop
asking him for advice about your
personal finances he can't say oh he
knew nothing about my personal finances
for Ding Dang sure I mean these two
things seem completely contradictory
well again I would say that I don't know
all the details and I must recognize
that as well no I I completely recognize
how you can produce two pieces of
evidence and and and a conclusion can be
drawn but I know hard to draw another
conclusion well I know from uh
experience in the past including when I
jump to conclusions about people and
then found that actually I've been
unfair on them that we just need to see
all the facts and it is the case but the
manner of Richard Sharp's appointment is
being looked at by the commissioner for
public appointments just to make sure
that everything was completely kosher um
and so again you know it's
absolutely understandable uh to think
aha this plus this equals that but my my
bitter experience is wait until you see
all the facts before coming to a
definitive conclusion okay we will wait
to see the facts is poorest Johnson
becoming a liability no
um I think Boris Johnson
um was a a very good prime minister and
I think that he has a lot to contribute
to public life in the future okay um
Nadim zahawi another investigation going
on of course into whether Nadine zahawi
broke the ministerial code over his tax
Affairs can you tell us when we should
expect that report is it next week
I don't know I know that Solario Magnus
is the independent advisor on these
issues who's having looked at it
um one to conclude his investigation as
quickly as possible and I think in fact
I know that Nadine wants the
investigation to be concluded as quickly
as possible so uh I've spoken about to
him about it
um I I know that Nadeem wants the thing
done with
um I I haven't spoken to Laurie Magnus I
wouldn't uh so but I I don't know uh and
and again I think it's in everyone's
interests that the matter is concluded
as quickly as possible uh but it's also
the case that when you've got someone
specifically appointed to be independent
then me providing a running commentary
on on the timings one could be
misconstrued understood if he's found to
have broken the ministerial code should
he lose his job well again it's a
serious thing to break the ministerial
code but again it's up to the prime
minister in possession of the full facts
I I know it's irritating when
politicians say oh we've got to wait for
the the result of the inquiry but once
you've set it up once you've got this
um uh independent person looking at all
the evidence I think
trying to
anticipate yes what he concludes and
therefore what follows what well you
know I completely understand that you
know it's it's melstrise
says it would be a difficult finding you
say it would be a serious thing I mean
it would be difficult wouldn't it again
you know I I I suspect that we'll find
out soon enough and then a judgment can
be made on that basis understood now
unsurprisingly all of this we've been
talking about the NHS we've been talking
about the financial allegations that are
being investigated is having an impact
on people's view of the conservative
party we had a surprise guest in calling
into our NHS phone in this week and I
just want to tell you what happened this
is Rod Stewart calling in to Sky News
I personally have been a touring for a
long time but I think this government
should stand down now and give the labor
party a go at it because this is
heartbreaking for the nurses it really
is heartbreaking in all my years of
living in this country I've never seen
it so bad
I feel like he's articulating what a lot
of your former voters are thinking well
uh I grew up listening towards you I'm a
huge fan of his um and uh all I would
say is that the government is absolutely
focused on solving the problems that rod
and others are worried about we're
absolutely focused on making sure that
we can cut waiting lists we're
absolutely determined to ensure that we
can uh uh half inflation that we can uh
reduce debt that we can grow the economy
and also that we can deal with the uh
illegal immigration problems stopping
the boats in the channel those
priorities are absolutely essential to
the government and of course there are
people uh like sarod and others who are
natural conservatives who have concerns
at the moment our job is to convince
them that on inflation on growth on
reducing debt on making sure that we cut
waiting lists and stop the boats that we
are delivering you see you know I don't
think anyone will dispute it which is
United's had a difficult hand to play
right you can have the back of Liz
truss's disastrous budget we've had a
backdrop of high inflation the
conservatives and power for over a
decade but the poles are moving in the
wrong direction I think we can have a
quick look this is a kind of yougov
tracker poll and you can see that there
hasn't actually been a bounce the polls
are moving in the wrong direction the
the Gap is still wide and if you look at
the leader approval ratings as well uh
when you compare Richardson actor
kirstan you can see that right at the
end Chris Thomas red line is going up
and Rishi sunax is dropping you know if
you're conservative and P going to be
looking at this you can be really
worried well again polls are snapshots
um this isn't a snapshot this is over
time no no that's why I chose it rather
than a snapshot uh evidence would
suggest that over the course of the last
few years it's very difficult to say how
politics is going to look in a year or
an 18 months time so again the you know
the the uh the evidence there shows they
their volatility actually of public
opinion on a variety of areas in the way
in which reputations can rise and fall
um but is that volatile there's been a
very significant lead for the labor
party for some time now uh and as as
there has been for opposition parties
during periods when governments have
been empowered during the middle of
their term in office the critical thing
though is
um people want to see a government that
is making an impact
um all of us can be commentators and can
be invited to offer a gloss on the polls
but the difference is that my job
my goals of the pause is no is no better
than anyone else's my job is to deliver
that's it though isn't it you said that
people want governments who are making
an impact yes you are a reformer right
you know you go into departments you're
not worried about breaking a few eggs
you look at Rishi CNAC you look at
Jeremy Hunter Chancellor
are they a bit timid no God no no no no
no I mean the the nigerial no well well
the the the thing is that
um being an effective manager of public
money and public services is not a sin
in my view but it is the case but first
of all we had to bring a stability and
we have and now we've set out areas
where we are reforming so Jeremy gave a
fantastic speech on Friday in which he
explained how it is that we can make the
country uh essentially the technological
Powerhouse of The Next Century how by
improving education having a culture of
Entrepreneurship making sure that we get
more people back into employment and
making sure that we have investment
everywhere across the country to level
up we can drive economic reform let's
talk about education shall we teachers
are striking next week
sorry are they right to you no I um um
my own son's school is going to be
affected by this I do sympathize with
the position that many teachers are in
but I would ask them respectfully not to
go on strike because I believe as the
education sector is do you think Keegan
has said you know you don't need to go
on strike to get her attention she cares
about improving because that's the whole
point isn't it teachers feel like it is
the only way to get to get people's
attention if you look at the ifs they
say that most teachers will see it five
percent real terms pay cut this year and
that's on the back of successive real
terms pay cuts over the last decade
we've got a recruitment crisis in
teaching it's no surprise it's no
Comfort to anyone to point out how
difficult economic circumstances over
are overall and that is why it is so
important and it's our top priority to
reduce inflation that is the best tax
cut the best pay rise that anyone that's
penalize that people could get is an
actual pay rise that would only
contribute to further inflation in the
future it would only create a spine I
thought it was a global inflation crisis
now you're saying teachers are to blame
for it no I'm not saying that teachers
to blame for an inflation crisis not at
all but I am saying that all of us have
a responsibility to recognize that when
public money is tight when we need to
reduce inflation when we need to get
that down we also need to make sure that
um pay Awards reflect that on on the
recruitment issue in teaching as well of
course pay is a factor but it's also the
case that we need to support teachers by
providing them with the right tools to
have effective discipline and behavior
in the classroom the other thing is that
at the overwhelming majority of teachers
go into teaching because they're
idealistic they want to transform the
opportunities of the next generation of
children so again making sure that we do
the right thing in education overall by
providing teachers with the tools to uh
deliver the curriculum effectively is
also important what would be a realistic
pay raise a fair pay rise for teachers
again um it's not for me to say but I
think the important thing is that uh the
the
program of conversations that teachers
and teaching unions are having with the
education secretary which I know the
education sector is committed to and
she's a warm and open person that is the
best route to a conclusion just finally
when you educational secretary I
remember there was a lot of talk about
what was termed as the blob people who
were resistant to your reforms are these
strikes an example of The Blob in action
no
thank you very much Michael gave good to
have on the program thank you very much
Sophie thank you
I had my interview with Michael Gove
there now a medium-sized economy in a
period of decline with poor productivity
or one of the world's richest countries
with Innovative Industries waiting to be
Unleashed well the chancellor tells us
it's the latter and wants an end to what
he describes as decline isn't about the
UK economy that he says is holding us
back but what is the view of business
and how is the government managing it
well we can try and find out Siobhan
Haviland is director general of the
British Chambers of Commerce she joins
us now thank you so much for being uh
with us um
towards the end of the into I'm just
kicking the desk towards the interview
uh they're under the interview there
with the leveling up secretary I was
trying to say you know is the government
doing enough is it being uh thoughtful
enough or is it just trying to kind of
steady the ship and he said no no it's
all about big ideas and he pointed to
the chancellor speech this week what's
your take is the government taking
enough risks
so I was at the chance of speech on
Friday
um and it was uh good to hear him being
really positive about British business
uh in this role with the chambers I have
the joy of traveling the country and
meeting businesses all over our regions
and Nations and you know we are we do
have amazing Innovative growing
businesses so we do need to be really
positive about that
um and it was a step in the right
direction but it is a framework uh we're
probably missing a couple of E's from
his framework on export and energy
um but what business really want to see
is action and changes and policies it
felt like there was a lot of words and
not that much in terms of policy do you
think that's fair yeah I think that's
fair I mean he did say that's what he
was laying out it's a step in the right
direction for a something that looks
like a strategy but what we really want
to see is on areas like export you know
that's a huge growth area for us as a as
a country we need to fix the Northern
Ireland protocol so we can trade more
easily with our biggest trading partners
we need to see support for businesses on
their energy bills of course the support
for businesses on energy was uh was
fantastic it's been over the last six
months but it's coming to an end in
March we've got a new uh package it's
much much lower than the last and when I
travel around the country and energy is
really energy bills are really a concern
for business and of course people
getting the right people to run their
business and you're talking there about
exports and also about getting the
protocol right the Northern Ireland
protocol the famous uh protocol
do you think that the government is I
guess reluctant to talk honestly about
the impacts of brexit for political
reasons
so
um
export businesses that export are more
resilient they're stronger they last
longer they pay better it's it's
incredibly important and those who had
been exporting to the EU have had huge
issues over the last two years I mean I
mean food and drink businesses who have
just stopped exporting to the EU because
it's too difficult and that is the
opposite of growth so getting the
Northern Ireland protocol away is going
to be really important to then going on
to fixing the bits of the trade
agreement that aren't working around
that around food and drink exports I
mean they really everywhere I go they
tell us it's a significant problem and
that's not just export of goods that's
use of Professional Services moving
people around Europe or all of that are
you optimistic that the government could
actually do something about it
we're hearing positive things about
Northern line protocol I was with the EU
ambassadors earlier this week they're
also feeling positive so that's going to
be a big a big thing if we can get past
that that's interesting is there any
sort of time scale that they're giving
on it
we're hoping for this quarter we really
need to see it this quarter because that
that way we can move on with the special
committees and we can fix the bits that
aren't working that's really interesting
uh just staying on the chancellor speech
he talked he railed against declinism he
was saying there's too much passes and
pessimism about the prospects of the UK
economy but you know
in a way I kind of think we're the only
G7 economy still smaller than before the
pandemic inflation is higher here in
comparison to other countries we've
talked about the trade hit that many
businesses have seen we're getting
poorer that's not decliners and that's
reality right
when I when I meet businesses of the UK
they do lay out the challenges that
we're that we're facing and some of the
fixes that we need on that but business
people are by their nature optimistic
they're forward-looking they're positive
and Friday after I saw the chance that I
went to Huntington I'm an amazing
business that is in Advanced Materials
unique Global IP founded here growing
here and that's what we want to talk up
that's what we want to see more of but
there are some issues that we need to
fix so everywhere I go businesses say I
can't get the people I need to grow my
business so we want to see a bit more on
that sort of skills development piece
there are some good things going on and
on that because there's been quite a
focus on the over 50s is that the rights
policy or are they perhaps people who
don't necessarily have the skills for
the jobs that need fill in it's part of
the answer it's part of the answer and
we're working with government on the
economically unactive the chance to talk
about it on Friday uh that might be
people over 50 coming back into the
workforce but actually we need to look
at child care so we can bring carers and
parents back into the workforce and
honestly we have 1.2 million open roles
in this country by the government's
estimate that's about 500 000 people and
when I go around the country businesses
always also tell us we need people from
uh the rest of Europe to come in and
work in this country so we really want
government to look at their shortage
occupation lists the structures that
allow them to bring in short-term visas
for people in areas like Hospitality
where they're really struggling we'll
talk about childcare a bit later it does
feel as if it's a really important topic
to talk about if you're talking about
getting people back into the workplace
right and there's also a big debate in
the conservative party about tax cuts
now the line from the chancellor is that
the best tax cut is getting inflation
down but do you think there is a role
for tax cuts so it's good for individual
for consumers because they feel there's
a bit more money in their pockets
obviously that's good for business and
businesses want to see uh taxes kept low
at the front end so that they have
enough cash to invest in their
businesses but actually what they really
want to see is better access to people
so they can grow their businesses
helping them with their with their
energy bills but also you know we have
huge opportunities in green Innovation
for example so how are we supporting the
green accelerators we've got across the
country how we're investing in
infrastructure so we can build our SME
Supply Chains It's that sort of Positive
Growth they want to see
um I just want to put a talk like I
guess uh just go out a little bit and
just talk a little bit about the state
of the economy and put it into some
context we talked about some of the
challenges whether it's trade whether
it's inflation do you think it's harder
for businesses now than it has been in
previous years you know even during
covid or during the financial crash or
things a bit more optimistic
if you'd ask me a year ago
where energy bills were really spiraling
and we had businesses with 200 3 and 400
increases they were saying to me this is
worse than covid
but the energy package has really helped
them with a little bit of forward view
we are now seeing inflation hopefully
peaking forecast to be five percent by
the end of the year look it's going to
be a hard year it's going to be a tricky
year
but supporting businesses Now isn't
about subsidies or handouts it's about
investing in those businesses so they're
sort of fit for the future to make the
most is make the most of it as we come
out of the difficult times it does feel
like inflation is such a huge thing
whether it's from a business perspective
you need to talk about the energy bills
um and at the worst being worsen uh the
pandemic but also of course for families
particularly thinking about food bills
and stuff like that a recent analysis in
the financial times suggested that on
present Trends the average polish family
will be richer than a British family by
2030 a Slovenian family in just 2024. I
mean is the UK now you know a poor
country with just a wealthy pocket in
London and the southeast do we need to
re-look at you know the kind of economy
we are
we need to use the chamber Network
around the country the structure we have
in place to support local business and
remember local businesses are people
they they employ local people they
support their communities you know we
saw that we had the leveling up
secretary earlier I said to Michael
Michael the chamber network has been
doing leveling up for 250 years so
support local businesses inject money
into the system let's use those solvency
too changes that the chance has been
talking about to help support and grow
local business because that helps local
people really interesting thank you very
much for being on the program thank you
this morning well let's get Logan's View
now at their party's Shadow education
secretary Bridget Phillipson joins us
now live from uh Central uh London I'm
Keen to talk to you about a whole range
of issues including strikes but just to
pick up on something we were just
talking about with Siobhan and the
interview just there she was saying that
there's no point about talking about
getting people back into the workplace
without talking about child care and you
want to guaranteed child care don't you
for all parents of children age between
nine months to 11 years how would that
work
well we have been listening to business
and parents about what's holding them
back and what's holding back our economy
and that does involve making sure that
we've got a modern child care system
that reflects the needs of parents and
children and how they live their lives
today so we are looking at how we
fundamentally rethink how we deliver
child care in our country so from the
end of Parental leave right through to
the end of primary school and the first
step we've set out around that is making
sure we deliver breakfast clubs for all
primary school children in England
because it's important that we get the
early years right and we'll have more to
say on that but also parents know that
their child care problems don't end when
their children start at school and so
many women and sadly women in particular
that I speak to are giving up jobs they
love or are cutting back on their hours
because child care just isn't there and
it's holding back our economy if you're
serious about growth you've got to be
serious about delivering a modern child
care system too you know what I'm going
to have to Pivot very quickly because
we've had some breaking news through and
you will understand when you hear what
that news is we've heard from the UK
prime minister on Nadine zahawi and if
you remember he's asked his advisor to
look into whether or not the Doom zahari
broke the ministerial code in relation
to his tax Affairs he's put out a
statement where he says it's clear that
there has been a serious breach of the
ministerial code he says as a result
I've informed you of my decision to
remove you from your position in
government so that there is a letter
from the prime minister to Nadim zahawi
saying that he has been removing him
from government so he's effectively in
sacked from the government because it is
clear to the Prime Minister there has
been a breach of the ministerial code
I'm going to bring you the full letters
just as soon as I can but Bridget
Phillips and what's your immediate
reaction to that
well it's not clear to me what the Prime
Minister has been waiting for it's been
as plain as day for weeks now that this
was going to be the outcome but because
I wish you soon acts weakness his
weakness within his own party and his
failure to put the country first as a
result it's taken a very long time to
get here it's just a shame it's taken
him so long that our country continues
to be sucked into this mire of sleaze
that the conservatives are delivering
for us and you know when Rishi soon that
first became prime minister she promised
us about integrity and accountability I
think we're a very very long way away
from that
uh just to bring you a bit more details
from the full letter that we have now uh
got this letter from the prime minister
to Nadim zahar we dated today he says
when I became prime minister last year I
pledged that the government I lead would
have integrity professionalism and
accountability at every level that is
why following new information which came
to light in recent days regarding your
personal financial arrangements and
declarations I asked the Laurie Magnus
the independent advisor and Minister's
interests to fully investigate this
matter you agreed and undertook to
cooperate fully with inquiry following
the completion of the independent
advisors investigation the findings of
which he has shared with us both it is
clear that there has been a serious
breach of the ministerial codes as a
result I've informed you of my decision
to remove you from your position in his
Majesty's government he goes on to say
that Nadim zahar we should be extremely
proud of his achievements over the five
years referencing the vaccine
procurement program
um in particular and the fact that he is
a kurdish-born Iraqi Refugee that's
something which people up and down this
country have rightly valued uh Rishi
Cena says in this letter but just to sum
summarize it is clear this morning that
the investigation has completed uh into
Nadim zahawi the findings have been
shared with both the Prime Minister and
Nadine zahawi himself and as a result
the uh the Prime Minister says it's
clear there has been a serious breach of
the ministerial code and as a result he
has been sacked from the government
let's go back shall we to Bridget
Phillipson and you say that it's taken
the Prime Minister a long time to reach
this conclusion has it the um
investigation was was finalized pretty
quickly and as soon as the results came
in he's gone
he didn't need the advisor to tell him
this and it's just not clear to me why
it's taken so long but the sad truth is
that Nadeem zahawi is one of a number of
cases that we've seen in recent months
in the conservative parties I also look
forward to the Prime Minister taking
action against Dominic Robb and I also
look forward to the Prime Minister
taking action against Zoella bravman who
herself was found to have broken the
ministerial Court rather than Zachary
invited her back into government I mean
it is just a joke for the prime minister
to suggest that somehow this is a
government that has got integrity and
accountability at his heart they are
Riven with sleeves they're just fighting
it out constantly amongst themselves and
it's the British people who suffer as a
result because it's all about the
conservative party and it's not about
what's right for our country we face
really big challenges right now but when
you've got this constant infighting and
when you've got a prime minister that is
so weak he can't stand up for what's
right and he kind of outsources that
judgment to others I think it tells you
everything you need to know about really
why it is time for a change in Britain
you know you say he's weak but he has
just sacked Nadeem zahawi uh this
morning after getting the evidence
through I guess those people how many he
really had
already had no choice but to sucker but
he should have sacked him weeks ago I
mean it was always going to end in this
way
um so you know why on Earth aren't we
also seeing action on Zoella bravaman
and Dominic Robin you know all the
Scandal that continues to envelop Boris
Johnson This Is Not Just One Bad Apple
this is right at the heart of the
conservative party and it speaks to the
prime minister's weakness and and his
weak position within his own party that
as a result he can't put the country
first
um do you think that there was an
argument that some close to Rishi Cena
might make that he is effectively doing
a cleanup a job from administrations
that have gone uh before him he wasn't
told the full facts by Nadine zahawi uh
he claims and also of course the Boris
Johnson allegations that you uh referred
to he would argue I guess that those are
more of a hangover from the previous
administration that he is now having to
deal with the consequences of
well he's sort of doing a very good job
at cleaning it up if this is what he's
claiming because you know the stench of
sleeves just hangs around the
conservative party you know yes Nadine's
a Harley but so many of them
um and I just I think it speaks to a
wider problem that you've had a
government that's been in charge now for
13 years which is ample time to build a
better Britain and rather than focusing
on what the British people want right
now they're just mired in this kind of
infighting and constant you know
problems that they face within their own
party I think politics is about
delivering for the British people right
now with the conservatives that isn't
what people are getting you know an NHS
on its knees our schools often many of
them crumbling in a terrible data that
the government refuses to publish about
the state of our schools growth at a
terrible level and so many people held
back I think Britain's besties really do
lie ahead of us but I don't see how we
get to that stronger and better position
as a country with Rishi sunak as prime
minister with the fundamental weakness
right at the heart of his government
at the same time um you know as we were
talking before Nadeem zahari has been
actually mentioned uh Dominic Robb the
allegations into him are being looked
into and it is right that due process is
followed in these uh very important
matters is it not
look there is just so much here of
course and you know due processes
followed in the Nadeem Sahari case and
due process has resulted in what we all
knew was going to happen in the first
place I think it speaks to the prime
minister's character and his judgment
that he hasn't been prepared to act
until now he doesn't need to wait for
other people to tell him what to do he's
the Prime Minister for goodness sake he
should just get on with it
he says that just to recap here the
Prime Minister Rishi sunak has
effectively sacked Nadeem zahawi from a
government he's asked him he has said
that he's decided to remove him from his
position in the government because it is
clear in his words that there's been a
serious breach of the ministerial code
that the letter from Rishi sunak to
Nadeem zahawi over his tax Affairs
um do you think that with all of the
scrutiny of this story that politicians
should have to publish their tax returns
I think the trouble with all of this and
partly by I think in some in a bizarre
kind of way it suits the government is
it makes all politicians look as bad as
one another and I think there is a real
risk that it undermines
um faith and politics and the ability of
you know politicians to seek to make
lives better for the people of our
country and the people that we represent
I have no issue at all with um with
publication of tax returns when it comes
to the Prime Minister and others and Kia
storm are set out today that he believes
that the Prime Minister the Deputy Prime
Minister and the chancellor and their
respective counterparts should publish
their tax returns I don't think that's
particularly particularly controversial
um and you know my own tax return
there's not nothing particularly
interesting for anybody to see it's it
seems to be the likes of Dean zahari and
others that have got something that
they're wanting to hide
um so you'd be happy to publish your own
at tax return I guess the other argument
for some is that it might mean that
people who've been in business or are
wealthy people maybe put off entering
Parliament
I think if you're paying your taxes
you've got nothing to worry about the
trouble is we've had people at the heart
of government including those
responsible for running our tax system
who haven't been doing what's expected
of and that's the trouble
um but I think it's reasonable in fact I
think it's a basic expectation of those
in government that they should be
following the rules that they set for
others
um I have to say one thing that I have
found quite interesting from the latter
is the very clear uh implication that
Richard sunac has sacked Nadeem zahar we
here hasn't allowed him uh the space to
write his own letter of resignation or
to leave on his terms I mean do you
think this is Russia sunak uh trying to
take charge of the situation
I think he's desperately scrabbling
around after weeks of failing to act
um it was always going to come to this
we had this ludicrous spectacle at Prime
Minister's questions this week where uh
Rishi Suna was defending Nadine to
Harvey in effect that was never going to
be a tenable position for the Prime
Minister I think he's just underlined
his own weakness within his party that
it's taken him so long to get to this
point
uh now um we are going to stay on the
story for the rest of the program we're
talking to Sam Cates in just a minute
but I do just want to squeeze in one
final question on the education strikes
next week because I know a lot of
parents watching this program are going
to be interested to know your answer on
it schools are facing rolling strikes
from this week a teacher's right to walk
out
well like all parents I don't want B
strikes to go ahead of course they will
be disruptive and I don't want children
to miss time in school but the reason
that they're happening is because
government ministers are refusing to
negotiate seriously and find a
settlement there's still time for these
strikes to be called off if Government
ministers are serious about getting
around the table and trying to find a
way through it but parents will also
know that teachers increasingly feel
undervalued and under-appreciated for
the brilliant work that they do that's
what they tell me when I'm out speaking
with teachers and school leaders and
over the last decade we've had a
government that hasn't taken education
seriously as a priority for our country
and that's reflected in the fact that
teachers have had real terms pay cuts
and unsurprisingly given the wider
pressures that we're seeing right now in
the economy and they come to the end of
the road so my you know my strong advice
to ministers would be the way that these
strikes are to be called off it's the
serious and proper negotiation and there
is still time so let's make it happen
and let's get to a position that
everyone can live with but right now you
know we've had five education secretary
trees in the last year a total lack of
seriousness in dealing with an issue
that's been on the horizon since the
summer so we do need to get progress
around this but it falls to ministers
and at the minute they're just blaming
others for their own failure to act
okay thank you very much uh indeed
Bridget Phillipson a rather different
interview this morning I'm sure than the
one you're expecting to have uh good to
talk
thank you just to recap on the breaking
news that we have had in in the last few
minutes the Prime Minister has sacked
Nadim zahawi as party chairman this is
after a report by his ethics advisor
into Nadeem zahawi's tax Affairs he says
in the letter following new information
which came to light in recent days
regarding your personal financial
arrangements and declarations I asked
sir Laurie Magnus the independent
advisor on Minister's interests to fully
investigate this matter you agreed and
then he says following the completion of
the investigation it is clear that there
has been a serious breach of the
ministerial code as a result I have
informed you with my decision to remove
you from your position in his Majesty's
government
well let's get some analysis on this
story uh shall we we can talk now to our
Deputy political editor Sam coats who's
with us this morning uh Sam do you think
there's a sense of inevitability to this
there was Sophie but it has taken eight
days since Nadim zahari issued a
statement uh defending himself uh a
seven-day investigation in order to come
to the conclusion that Richie sunac has
made this morning that Nadim zahawi is
out of his government now it's
extraordinary really that just a year
ago or so Nadine zahawi was
contemplating trying to become Prime
Minister of this country yet what had
already happened with his tax Affairs
ended up essentially sowing the seeds
for his dismissal for it's a blunt
dismissal doesn't look like there was an
opportunity given to Nadine zahalby to
resign his dismissal from government now
he is out one time quite popular
Minister he was been campaigning for his
job over the last uh seven days or so he
was in checkers with the Prime Minister
just a few days ago he's been leaning on
colleagues to back him his aides have
been made taking the case to keep him in
government but no this morning Rishi
sunak makes clear he has decided that
Nadine zahawi is out and out in a pretty
brutal fashion but we've got more
information for you Sophie because we
know why in quite a lot of detail
because in addition to the letter that
Downing Street has released from the
prime minister to Nadine zahawi
dismissing him we also have the letter
it's a four-page letter from solori
Magnus to the Prime Minister outlining
why Nadine zahawi couldn't remain in
government and I have to say Sophie it's
one of the most detailed and unsparing
assessment that I can remember from an
independent ministerial advisor on
ethics about a serving cabinet minister
and makes absolutely clear in pitiless
detail why Nadine zahari could not stay
in his job I've got the letter in front
of me let me just run run you through
some of the key points that it makes
essentially the conclusion that the
independent ministerial advisor has got
to is that all the period through 2021
and 2022 when hmrc was investigating
Nadine zahari's case is that he didn't
realize that he was the subject of a
formal investigation and therefore
didn't tell any of the relevant people
that any of the relevant people that he
should have done like permanent
secretaries in the education department
the permanent secretary when he became
Chancellor which oversees hmrc Nadine
zahari didn't admit to them that he was
under investigation by hmrc Laurie
Magnus has found and he claims Nadine
zahari claims that that's because whilst
he was aware of a few inquiries he
didn't think that that amounted to be in
under investigation and basically Laurie
Magnus just says that's nonsense he says
that that impression that he uh
ministers are expected uh to to
understand what that means uh and I
consider this is a lorry Magnus Rising I
consider that an hmrc investigation of
the nature faced by Mr zahari would be a
relevant matter for a minister to
discuss and declare as part of their
Declaration of interest and it's the
kind of thing that you should speak to
your permanent secretary by senior civil
servant in your department about and
it's that failure that failure to tell
the education permanent secretary and
the the permanent secretary uh to the
treasury
um and uh basically he is a fairly
unimpressed with uh Nadim zahawi uh
suggesting uh that he didn't think that
he was uh personally under investigation
uh he goes on to criticize the public
statements of Nadim zahawi uh Nadim
sahawi uh saying in public uh that these
um uh people have falsely claimed that
the serious Fraud Office the National
Crime agency and hmrc are looking into
me let me be clear I am not aware of
this I haven't been not told of this
um now Nadine zahari told Laurie Magnus
that he made that statement because he
was under the impression that he was
answering hmrc's queries but was not
under investigation uh but Laurie Magnus
said that he considers an individual
subject to the hmrc process faced by Mr
zahawi should have understood that he
was under investigation by hmrc and that
this was a serious matter incredible Mr
zahawi's case for the defense was that
even though hmrc are asking me questions
I didn't realize that that amounted to
an investigation and Lori Magnus the
investment banker has been appointed
Rishi sunax independent ethics advice
just went right I believe that in the
slices clearly you should have known
that that amounted to uh uh to an
investigation and you should not have
made those public statements you should
not have failed to declare it to the
pertinent secretaries uh in your
department and that's why I think that
credibility gap that I think Lori Magnus
feels that he's found between Nadim
zahawi's uh public statement his
statements inside government and uh what
was really going on because Laurie
Magnus has been able to talk to hmrc
about the long-running investigation he
doesn't say how big the payment was that
Nadine zahawi had to pay back to hmrc he
doesn't say uh indeed whether there was
a penalty although we believe that there
was as hmlt uh say that they um uh as an
hmrc found uh what Nadine zahari
characterizes as carelessness but there
was a penalty to pay uh for that so he
didn't go into the private tax Affairs
of this but Laurie Magnus does basically
saying because you made those statements
internally in government and to the
public which I don't think really match
with the facts you've got to go now so
if there's a really big and important
political Point here because a lot of
people for the last couple of weeks have
been asking why did Richie seem like a
point Nadine Zohar when the first place
given that there were lots of stories in
the media about Nadine zahawi's tax
Affairs why didn't he just ask what was
going on now Downing Street had been
absolutely clear that there were no
Flags there were no warnings from civil
servants that there was a problem with
Nadine zahawi's tax Affairs because the
matter had been settled it was concluded
before Rishi tsuna came along but there
has been this this issue still
persisting why didn't Rishi sunak asked
basically ask more questions why didn't
the cabinet secretary uh perhaps tell
Richie sunak that there was this big
fairly recent issue that Nadine zahawi
had had to deal with and and what this
letter does what this four-page letter
from the Independent ministerial advisor
to Rishi symptoms to sort of give a
different reason for for sacking him
basically saying that there's things
that Richardson couldn't have known that
make uh Nadim zahawi's position in
government all but untenable this uh the
public statements about how he wasn't in
under investigation by hmrc when he was
something that Laurie Magnus could only
says he can only have found out by
talking to hmrc not something that
Richardson was particularly in a
position to do when he was appointing
jobs in his first cabinet back in the
Autumn and basically says only by doing
my investigation and talking to the
permanent secretaries who were told of
this investigation while it was going on
including uh the permanent Secretary of
the Treasury then Tom Schuller who of
course was overseeing with Nadine zahawi
hmrc so I mean it is just extraordinary
nazim zahari involved in discussions
with the tax man and being Chancellor
overseeing hmrc which does these
negotiations all of that happening at
the same time but but essentially what
Laurie Magnus has done as well as giving
an unsparing account of why Nadine
zahari can't keep his job is also in to
some degree uh providing cover a shield
for Richie sunac
exculcipating the Prime Minister from
not asking enough questions saying it's
only because I know these other things
that were not in the public domain that
were not the subject of public dysplasia
because of my essentially six day seven
day investigation that that we've
uncovered the real reasons why you
should get rid of him so so some attempt
at shielding the Prime Minister from the
for for from the Fallout but it's a
brutal letter uh the one from the
Independent ministerial advisor Sophie
it just it just is it it concludes uh
that um uh My overall judgment is that
Mr zahawi's conduct as a minister has
fallen below the high standards that
that of prime minister you rightly
expect from those uh who serve in your
government uh the one thing that Laurie
Magnus does say is that uh Nadine zahari
fully cooperated I think he felt he had
a case to make uh that he didn't know he
was under full investigation he didn't
realize that these things were a problem
but as you've been hearing uh Lori
Magnus misses out of the water the idea
that Nadine zahawi could be going around
saying he wasn't under investigation
failing to tell permanent secretaries
that he had been or was under
investigation all because the questions
in Nadim zahawi's view as um as he told
the ministerial advisor didn't amount uh
to a proper formal probe nonsense
basically is what uh Laurie Magda says
and that's why this morning Nadim zahari
is no longer part of the government no
longer conservative party chairman and
there's a reshuffle underway
extraordinary as you say sam an
unsparing letter there by Sir Laurie
Magnus leading to Rishi sunak a
dismissing at Nadim zahawi not given at
the right to resign himself Sam we're
going to come back to you don't go
anywhere because we're going to have
lots more coverage of this as the
morning rolls on but we can get some
further reaction now from the mayor of
Greater Manchester Andy Vernon thanks
for being on the program a bit of a
different interview to the one we're
expecting what is your reaction to the
sacking of Nadeem zahawi
well my my kind of first reaction uh
Sophia is that the government really
must learn lessons from this situation
this
um conclusion has felt inevitable hasn't
it for for a long time and yet it's been
allowed to dominate pretty much most of
January when there is probably the worst
crisis in the National Health Service
that I can remember and also we've got
collapsing public transport around the
country people can't get to work and
attention should have been on those
issues absolutely those issues because
they're critical for millions of people
and yet the airwaves have been taken up
with this and the government has to
learn a lesson from this this should
have been dealt with much more quickly
um uh Mr zahari should have been asked
to step aside uh even from his role
before the conclusions of this inquiry
because it shouldn't have been allowed
to dominate in this way and as we can
see it's not just this now there are
other investigations uh ongoing as well
so they must learn lessons uh from this
and get government Focus where it needs
to be on the very serious situation that
there is out there for millions of
people struggling with the cost of
living crisis ambulances queuing outside
of hospitals train timetables that are
just non-existent in large parts of the
country those are the things that the
British public urgently need their
government to focus on
there's been a lot of pressure on Rishi
sunak over there it's not least because
his first speech as prime minister he
pledged to lead a government of
Integrity professionalism and
accountability
um is there an argument that by sucking
Nadim tahawi in this way as soon as he
got the conclusions of the report not
allowing him at the right to resign
himself he is showing a strength on the
issue
well Knox I think the mistake that he
made I've already pointed to which is he
should have asked Mr zahari temporarily
to step aside from his role uh while
this investigation was going on so that
uh it wouldn't dominate uh in the way
that it that it has done and that was
not uh done and that's why I say the
government does need to uh to to look at
the way it's handled this and do things
very differently it's become a bit of a
Hallmark of this government hasn't it
where we've had uh you know the bullying
allegations against ministers just
rumbling away all of the time and the
problem with that is it takes sort of
much needed oxygen away from the issues
that need to be that need to be debated
and this is one of the things that
frustrates people about Westminster it
will obsess on something like this but
it will largely ignore the fact that the
the timetable on the main Railway line
in this country that links the main
cities of this country collapsed
yesterday thousands and thousands of
people had their weekend plans literally
at torn uh by Avanti West Coast and yet
where is that who is debating that who
is speaking up for those people in the
media well I'm trying to I came on today
to try and do that for them and yet
we're talking about this you know a kind
of a a Westminster
um concocted uh mess basically which
they should have dealt with much much
earlier and and that I think brings out
what's a lot of what's wrong with this
country at the moment and a lot of what
is really frustrating people people are
genuinely struggling to get to work to
live their lives to pay the bills and
they don't see that fully reflected in
what's going on in Westminster and what
is then debated in the media I can feel
your frustration at not being able to
talk enough in this interview about
trains buses and you know the area that
you represent you'll forgive me because
this is quite a big breaking story that
we weren't expecting
that though
but shouldn't you go with that because
is it right that we obsess on this the
prime minister's made his decision he
made it too late but should we now go on
to what's going on in the National
Health Service and on the railways I
don't know I mean I'm just I I think
this is the problem and we repeatedly
get ourselves into these uh Westminster
dramas that that actually take attention
away from the things that most people
are really really frustrated about so
would you like then a line to be drawn
under this now for labor to stop you
know attacking the Prime Minister uh for
it for people to say look you know the
decisions we made let's move on let's
talk about other things
no I think you should do two other
things today I think it should uh deal
with the Dominic Rob situation in the
way that I've I've described
um and that isn't going my investigation
is ongoing it's so important to hear
everyone who wants to get evidence right
exactly but when ministers are subject
to Serious investigations like that I
think they should temporarily step aside
from their roles the Boris Johnson
situation uh needs to be dealt with
questions need clearing up but by
failing to do that they then Dominate
and that's the issue that I'm kind of
raising I guess here you know from our
perspective we're trying to keep public
transport going we're trying to support
colleagues in the NHS you know we're
trying to resolve some of the disputes
out there uh in the in the fire service
and yet those things are much bigger
than this but they are going uh really
sometimes unreported I often see people
saying that on social media who is
speaking about the fact that I can't get
a train to London today and my life has
been completely turned upside upside
down and I don't know I just think we're
living in very strange times where the
disconnect between what's going on in
Westminster and the rest of the country
is getting bigger and bigger people are
getting more and more frustrated about
it and the government really needs to
hear that and it needs to sort of deal
quickly with these things and put them
to one side and get the focus back on
where it's uh where it should be I'd
love to know how much time has been
taken up in in Downing Street and uh
Whitehall this week dealing with this
situation I bet they've spent more time
on this than they have on on the other
things I've mentioned
you talked a lot about trains I would
like to talk to you about Stripes as
well while we have you and of course
teachers are walking out and rolling
strikes from next week do you support
them
I I do support people who have struggled
to pay their bills you know you can't
say it's wrong for someone who's had
real terms pay cuts for years and then
finds themselves in the cost of living
crisis to try and protect themselves
what I would say is it should never come
to this what happened to getting around
the negotiating table and sorting things
out that's how things used to be done
and it's how things should be done
always in these situations it's never
the case that one side should get
everything that they want and the other
side's completely wrong there's always a
negotiation to be had and what I've
observed at the moment there's a sort of
culture of letting issues rumble on and
playing the politics of the situation
trying to turn the public against the
nurses or against the teachers or
against the paramedics and the
firefighters rather than actually
sitting down and solving things you know
these problems on the railways so they
are entirely fixable they could be fixed
uh tomorrow and yet they are allowed
just to rumble on and rumble on and
that's what I mean about government
really starting to get a grip I'm
focusing on things that matter to people
and not allowing just these multiple
disputes to to continue you can't blame
people who've had real terms pay cuts
for years who then find themselves in
the cost of living because you can't
just expect them to keep going to work
and sit there as their problems at home
Mount up how can they kind of give all
of their attention to our kids in the
classroom if they're worried about
what's going on with with their rent and
and their ability to to keep their home
I mean it's just basic isn't it you've
got to help people in a time like this
you've got to talk to people and I would
I as a minister I'm not just saying this
sort of like you know so I wouldn't do
it myself I do do it myself I am talking
to our firefighters we are trying to
resolve issues here you know we used to
have a culture of that in this country
didn't we used to be called beer and
sandwiches and smoke-filled rooms and
all of that what's happened to fixing
things negotiating and getting the
country functioning again it seems
somehow that's out of fashion and it
really shouldn't be
okay thanks so much for being on the
program uh Mr Burnham I promise that we
would invite you all again sometime soon
to talk about some of the issues I know
we were planning on doing this morning
buses next time yeah we will do more
questions on trains and buses that's a
promise Andy Burnham thank you very much
uh indeed thank you
well the breaking news uh this morning
if you are just joining us the Prime
Minister has sacked Nadeem zahawi at the
party uh chairman after the conclusions
of a report by his by his Essex ethics
advisor into Nadim zahawi's uh tax
Affairs uh concluded that he has in the
words of Sir Lauren Magnus his conduct
as a minister has fallen below the high
standards that as prime minister you
rightly expect from those who serve in
your government effectively concluding
that Mr zahari did not tell people that
he was under investigation by hmrc when
he should have done so Rishi sunac
saying that as a result he has taken a
decision to remove Nadeem zahawi from
his position in the government and the
findings it says he says it's clear that
there has been a serious breach of the
ministerial code
well to speak to Michael Gove the
leveling up secretary just moments
before the reports was published I would
quite like to play you some of that
interview because I did ask Mr Gove at
the time when we could expect the report
from Solari Magnus
see what you think of his answer
once the conclude his investigation as
quickly as possible and I think I know
that Nadeem wants the investigation to
be concluded as quickly as possible so
I've spoken about to him about it
um I I know that Nadeem wants the thing
done with
um I I haven't spoken to Laurie Magnus I
wouldn't uh so but I I don't know uh and
and again I think it's in everyone's
interests that the matter is concluded
as quickly as possible but it's also the
case that when you've got someone
specifically appointed to be independent
then me providing a running commentary
on on the timings one could be
misconstrued understood
well given of course that that report
was published I think less than an hour
after Michael gave said that I think as
soon as possible was doing quite a lot
of work in that uh interview but we can
go straight back to our Deputy political
editor at Sam Coates now for some more
reaction uh to the news that Nadine
zahawi has been sent I've just been
looking at the letter from origi sunak
he starts off by saying when I became
prime minister last year I pledged the
government I lead would have integrity
professionalism and accountability at
every level how important is it
politically for Rishi sunak to be seen
to be dealing with this decisively
well I think you can tell from the
language of Richardson that's letter
that he realizes he has to be seen to be
as brutal as possible right now about
Nadine zahari's tax Affairs partly
because the scale of the mess that this
affair has left him in as well of course
as Nadine zahawi who this morning is out
of government and it's because precisely
because Rishi sunak came into government
making out that he was a clean break
from the from the past as uh the kind of
government that Boris Johnson ran uh
with all of the conduct issues and
conflict of issue of Interest issues uh
that existed in the Boris Johnson regime
Rishi Cena came in going I'm going to be
different yet here we are this is the
second cabinet minister that has had to
resign under Rishi sunak Gavin
Williamson Left Post last year over
exchanges with different conservative
MPS that uh basically he felt didn't
live up to standards in public life that
you need to espouse now you've got
Nadine zahari out and Rishi tsuna trying
to be as brutal as possible and you can
see on your screen uh the strap line
there Nadine zahari removed from
government because that's the language
in the letter from Rishi sunak not I'm
giving you an opportunity to resign it's
not we discuss the issue when you agree
to vacate your post it's I've removed
you because Rishi zenac rather urgently
needs to look like he's back in the
driving seat of this affair because it's
Richie sunak he's had quite a lot of
questions about why this affair has been
allowed to drag on so long about why if
the issue was in the media before uh
Richardson that became prime minister he
nevertheless appointed him uh and why
it's taken uh all so long so I I think
this is Richie sunac trying to act and
he's helped in that Sophie by the report
that we've had the four page report
that's also been released by The
Independent ministerial advisor Laurie
Magnus only a recent appointee to the
job and investment banker who's taken up
the perhaps rather thankless task of
investigating what's going on uh when
people do wrong in Rishi Cena's
government and in that rather unsparing
uh report he sets out why Nadine zahawi
has had to be sacked this morning and
really
there are a couple of reasons for it but
it's not Laurie Magnus does not conclude
that Nadine zahari had to go because he
was in dispute with the tax man because
he ended up having to pay back a lot of
tax and because that ended up generating
a fine that that's not the reason this
morning that the independent ministerial
advisor says that Nadim zahawi is out
instead the reason the serious breach of
the ministerial code that's led to the
sacking is something rather different it
is that Nadine zahar we maintained all
the way through the period that he was
education secretary and part of the time
that he was Chancellor where his job
also included being in charge of hmnc
all the way through that Nadine zahawi
maintained internally and externally so
to his permanent secretaries and to the
public that he was not under
investigation by hmrc when he was that's
the nub of the four-page letter from the
Independent ministerial investigator
because Nadine's harm we didn't come
clean to his permanent secretary at the
treasury come clean to the permanent
secretary at the department for
Education about that investigation uh
that's the reason the primary reason
that Nadine zahawi is this morning out
after the ministerial advisor uh
concluded that he hadn't lived up to the
high standards of the ministerial code
and in doing so actually Laurie Magnus
provides afford a little bit of cover
for Rishi sunak obviously one of number
10's priorities will make to make sure
that although this episode is
undoubtedly awful for the government
second cabinet minister to resign in a
matter of months under the Prime
Minister that promised to restore
integrity and professionalism to public
life they want to Shield Rishi sunak
from as much of the blowback as much of
the Fallout as possible basically by
saying well it wasn't uh he's getting
this money not because of things that
Richardson could have known but because
of things that Nadine zahawi failed to
declare before Richard Cena became prime
minister so in some way looking to
Shield Rishi soon act there but it's
still absolutely brutal and it suggests
that Richard Cena continues to have to
as it were deal with the consequences of
the Boris Johnson raging but I think
there's almost a sense of
the sense of self-pity inside Downing
Street that they're just having to
continually trying to mop up lots of
things that took place before Rishi
sunak became prime minister there was
the Liz truss era and then of course
since uh 2019 the Boris Johnson era they
can't get on the front foot this
government and haven't really been able
to since Richie sunap became prime
minister because of all of these issues
Michael Gove trying in the interview
with you to point out some massive
things that this government is going to
attempt to do uh whether it's admitting
liability of government ministers about
grenfell trying to sort that out by
signing a series of contracts with the
private sector in order to deal with
issues around cladding whether it's
tackling the strikes trying to take the
public on side given those train strikes
and school strikes given that it's an
attempt to sort out the Northern Ireland
protocol it's a huge long list the
government ministers would like to talk
about Richie soon acts claimed to trying
to win the next election it's all based
on being the competent prime minister
who isn't like his predecessors who does
do deals and sort problems out and yet
there are just more problems exploding
on his plate uh because of the nature in
part because the nature of the cabinet
that Rishi felt he had to a point when
he came into office there's no doubt
that at that moment in late October
early November the man you can see on
screen Nadine zahawi was put in the
cabinet as part of a complicated
reshuffle because the conservative part
is essentially broken and Nadine zahawi
was part of trying to stitch together
all the different factions because Rishi
Cena ultimately didn't feel that strong
on the day that he entered number 10
entered the building that you can see on
your stream he was trying to appease
factions uh glue the conservative party
back together and in doing so it was
taking in many of the people who had
been part of Boris Johnson and part of
Liz truss's team but many of those
people it's turning out having some
issues whether it was gav and Williamson
who was in and is now out whether it's
Nadine zahawi who this morning has been
fired questions also about no less than
the Deputy Prime Minister Dominic Raab
could he be the next cabinet minister in
the firing line because of questions
about how he's behaved to staff some
suggestions of maybe double-digit uh
numbers of complaints about his behavior
while he has been a minister these
ongoing issues from months and years
past still disrupting uh Rishi sinat's
government so yes your question was does
uh Richardson have to look brutal yes he
does because he's trying to draw a line
under stuff but it's really really hard
because there's just an awful lot of
stuff given the number of years the
conservative have been in government the
nature of the cabinet that Rishi sinak
had to appoint taking in so many people
uh from the Boris Johnson era and the
Liz truss era uh perhaps some hint that
that they're not that necessarily all
the team that he was picked if he wasn't
dealing with the inheritance that he had
because he had to glue back together the
conservative party and now all of these
things exploding on his plate are
stopping his government getting the kind
of momentum that his cabinet heard only
this week at an away day and checkers it
is needed to try and convince the public
that this government is uh one that
deals with the public the priorities
that the public has sorts out problems
and is on those sites so difficult when
again we're talking about the tax
Affairs and the failure to come clean of
a senior cabinet minister who this
morning is out of the government because
of issues that have been around for the
best part of a year very very difficult
for Rishi sunak but an effort underway
to try and protect him the best that
they can in number 10 by saying that the
reason that he's gone is failure to come
clean uh before Richard became's prime
minister that when Nadine zahari is out
this morning yeah we'll have to find out
as you you say sam whether or not that
will be adequate to draw a line under
this matter when it comes to the
reputation of Rishi Cena we'll be coming
back to you shortly Sam thank you as
always for your analysis well some coats
there are saying that Rishi sunite needs
to show he's was brutal in dealing with
Nadeem zahawi not allowing him the
opportunity to resign instead making it
pretty clear he was sacked he says I've
informed you in the letter to Mr zahawi
of my decision to remove you from your
position in his Majesty's government
well if the prime minister is trying to
look brutal brutal is also the word to
describe the conclusions of this report
by Sir Laurie Magnus who is the new
ethics advisor to the Prime Minister I
just want to bring you a bit of what he
says in that report I consider that Mr
zahawi in holding the high privilege of
being a minister of the crown has shown
insufficient regard for the general
principles of the ministerial code Mr
zahami's Conductor Minister has fallen
below the high standards that as prime
minister you rightly expect from those
who serve in your government
goes on to say given the nature of the
investigation by hmrc which stated
started prior to his appointment as
Secretary of State for education on the
15th of September 2021 I consider that
by failing to declare hmrc's ongoing
investigation before July 2022 despite
the ministerial Declaration of Interest
form including the specific prompts on
tax Affairs and hmrc Mr zahari failed to
meet the requirement to declare any
interest which might be thought to give
rise to a conflict so that key there
effectively saying that Nadeem zahawi
did not tell the relevant people that he
was under investigation by hmrc and as a
result fell below the standards expected
by the prime minister so that was the
conclusions of the report by Solari we
can also bring you the letter that the
Prime Minister Rishi sunak sent to
Nadeem zahari this morning and has made
public as well in the letter he says
when I became prime minister last year I
pledged that the government I lead would
have integrity professionalism and
accountability at every level he goes on
to say following the completion of the
independent advisors investigation the
findings of which he is shared with us
both it's clear there has been a serious
breach of the ministerial code as a
result I've informed you of my decision
to remove you from your position in his
Majesty's government so that letter
there from uh Rishi sunac to Nadeem
zahawi saying that he effectively is
being sacked for failing to
declare his interests and he says there
has been a serious breach of the
ministerial code
well it's been a bit of different uh
program for us this morning at Labor
Shadow education secretary was probably
expecting to talk more about the
teaching strikes instead she was asked
for her reaction to the breaking news
today let's listen
it's not clear to me what the Prime
Minister has been waiting for it's been
as plain as day for weeks now that this
was going to be the outcome but because
I wish you soon acts weakness his
weakness within his own party and his
failure to put the country first as a
result it's taken a very long time to
get here it's just a shame it's taken
him so long that our country continues
to be sucked into this mire of sleaze
that the conservatives are delivering
for us and you know when rushy soon that
first became Prime Ministry promised us
that integrity and accountability I
think we're a very very long way away
from that
well that was Labor's reaction we have
had some fresh reaction from Michael
Gove and I spoke to him earlier this
morning he was pretty occasion should we
say about the fact that this uh
explosive report was about to hit our
inboxes at less than an hour after our
interview but we have managed to catch
up with him let's have a listen
clearly decided that it was a moment
foreign
to drag his reputation and the
government's reputation through the mud
why is it taking so long for him to a
second I think it's important in all of
these situations whenever allegations
are made that they are investigated
impartially independently and in full
and that's what the Prime Minister
wanted to to see that is what has
happened we recognize that whenever
allegations are made particularly
serious allegations they require proper
investigation we don't want a
precipitative rough to judgment but we
do once all the facts are laid out need
decisive action and that is what the
Prime Minister has given today decisive
action but only after a full and proper
investigation due process then effective
decision making
the first hundred days sat for two
minutes there's another one when they're
investing
yeah Integrity is about doing the right
thing and doing the right thing is
making sure that when allegations are
come up like this that you have a proper
investigation
um and then once the facts are fully
established then you make that judgment
people are innocent until proven guilty
or other ones so therefore it is
absolutely vital that you follow the
rules
um and the prime minister is absolutely
determined to ensure that he runs the
government on the basis of
professionalism and integrity and that's
what we've seen here a professional
independent advisor and a decision that
reflects the Integrity of the government
but are you worried that your party now
has the reputation your critics will say
you're the party of slaves well critics
will always try to find a reason to
attack Shuffle the most important thing
for those of us in government is not to
respond to commentary
um but to get on with delivery what we
need to do is to make sure that our
pledges do all of inflation to reduce
debt to grow the economy to stop the
boats crossing the channel and to cut
waiting list to deliver and finally on
on this topic
critics will also say that Richards you
know his political judgment is weak he
hasn't got the strength required to make
the tough political decisions women
pride and that's been demonstrated this
week strength is there exhibited when
you do the right thing strength is about
standing by your principles and the
promises principles are that you have a
proper investigation when someone is uh
you know
in this way that seems to be to be the
right to the strong the appropriate
response okay thank you
uh Michael Gove there saying that the
Prime Minister Richie sumac has acted
decisively that he's been strong in the
way that he has stacked Nadim zahari
also saying that it is right to wait for
the investigation to be concluded before
taking action at people are innocent
before proven uh guilty uh Michael Gove
there giving the government's defense
for the way that they have handled the
story of Nadim zahawi's at tax affairs
well let's bring back in shall we add
actually political credit to Sam coats
for a bit more reaction I've been
listening to what Michael Glover said
there and also the labor response we've
had from Andy Burnham and also Bridget
Phillipson who was saying that look this
investigation has taken eight days to
complete there's little uh that we found
out that we didn't know already in their
View and that the Prime Minister should
it be much speedier in getting this done
but also at Nadeem zahar we should have
stepped aside while the investigation
was taking place do you think they have
a point or do you think that now that
action has been taken this will help
draw a line under the matter
foreign
tends to hurt tends to land when it
falls into a bit of a bigger pattern
here and I think there just is a little
bit of an issue about just how quickly
Rishi sunak tends to act when things
happen there is some grumbling about
whether it's uh initiating big plans
whether it's devising policy whether
it's coming up with Solutions whether
it's responding to things there is just
a bit of grumbling that I've been
picking up in recent days about Rishi
soon academic team being a little slow
to get on the front foot on things and I
suspect that that's what one of the
problems but It's Tricky it's been
tricky for them and that's not to pass
judgment or otherwise on uh uh uh uh uh
on um on the situation but it was just
11 days ago at Prime Minister's question
time so that that's the prime minister's
question time two ago that um Rishi Cena
was saying that Nadine zahari had
answered all questions in full about his
tax Affairs so that footage of the Prime
Minister standing in the Commons talking
about teams of Harvey from really the
very very very recent past will be now
put against the decision that he's had
to make completely different decision on
the basis of the Laurie Magnus
independent advisor letter to get rid of
him so so we do have a situation where
Rishi sunak has had to do a total 180
degree pivot and those things do
actually take a few more days than than
you might want because he's had to go
from defending him at the dispatch box
to dispatching him as it were and that
does just take a little bit of time just
to to get those gears uh grinding and in
order and what Downing Street are trying
to do this morning is through the
release of the letter which makes it
clear that the sacking of uh that he was
always quite brutal and by the uh
release of the correspondence with
Laurie Magnus the independent advisor
which makes it clear that Nadim zahawi
uh has been sacked uh for not telling
his permanent secretary he was under
investigation for not giving
particularly robust public statements or
basically not telling the truth uh uh
when he was speaking in public that's
the clear implication of the Laurie
Magnus letter and for failing more
generally uh to uphold standards in
public life I think that is a reference
uh to the decision of hmrc to impose a
penalty in Nadeem zahawi which I I Lori
Magnus hints but doesn't say completely
explicitly uh ought to be incompatible
uh with staying as a minister so those
are the three reasons and but what the
letter does do is provides something
else for Downing Street to point to as a
reason for Nadim zahawi to be sacked
this morning other than Rishi sunak not
asking questions about stories that are
in the public domain not really
following up in great deal of detail
about what was going on in his personal
affairs even though there were plenty of
questions because of course Sophie none
of this and it's worth saying we should
have said a bit of this last week none
of this would have come to light without
journalism and in this case it was Anna
Isaac now of the Guardian I think then
of the independent who brought this
entire thing to the fore by revealing
that there are questions over Nadine
zahawi's tax Affairs and it was the
statement issued in response to that uh
that Rory Magnus picks up in his letter
that's been released by Downing Street
this morning he implies that that was
the response which said there's no
investigation was not a fair
representation of the truth because
natim zahari was well aware of the
inquiries by hmrc into his tax Affairs
Nadeem zahawi's defense was I didn't
realize that amounted to an
investigation Laurie Magnus says come on
that's clearly not quite right and it
therefore the public statements and the
internal government positions that
Nadine zahawi uh took During the period
that he was investigated by hmrc which
included the period where he was
Chancellor with responsibility for hmrc
those public statements did not
constitute uh or basically what weren't
true and that constituted the bridge in
the material code and that's why it's
being sacked uh this morning so that's
the case for defense uh for Richie
sooner it was all about uh Boris era and
Liz truss era problems in government
rather than a failure to dig earlier on
in his time in government that's the
problem uh Downing Street by the way
safely there'll be no appointment of a
success
chief executive of the Tory party will
take over the deems of Harvey's duties
no appointment today of a successor okay
that's interesting to know Sam one
thought to finish on it feels to me like
there's an awful lot of big
big benches right now which can of
course be unhelpful shall we say to the
current prime minister you know Boris
Johnson Liz truss Nadim zahawi going to
the back benches how do you predict
who's going to be
nothing to Harmony is a popular Minister
he got great kudos for his work as a
vaccines Minister he tried to go for the
leadership for which you need a
considerable grounds full of support but
I have to say even amongst people who
backed him for the leadership there
wasn't much sympathy for him the
question is what is Nadeem Sahari going
to do is even the stairs and MP live
dem's calling for him to stand down but
you're right I think there's wider
trouble on the Tory back benches
malcontent former ministers cabinet
ministers and as you say prime ministers
the the Tory party is quite broken after
the last few years of turmoil and and
this won't help
um thank you very much as always for
your analysis uh very busy day for us
today on the program so always good to
have your uh analysis I'll let you go
back to reading uh the full
recommendations for the report
well lots of news a breaking news for us
this morning and the situation changing
very quickly from the initial interview
that we did with Michael Gove where he
said that look I've got no idea we don't
know I can't tell you when the report is
being unveiled only for that to drop in
our inboxes just before 9 00 a.m this
morning at the full report by the ethics
advisor sir Laurie and also of course
the reply from the Prime Minister where
he says that he's made the decision to
remove Nadim zahawi from his role as
chairman no opportunity from Nadine
zahawi to resign and it was a damning
report into the former Tory chairman
concluding that he did not declare the
hmrc investigation when he was initially
appointed as Chancellor and as a result
he has now been sacked from the
government
well that is it for this week's safety
Ridge on Sunday we will have lots more
coverage on the sacking Nadine zahawi at
the top of the hour so do stay with us
thank you as always for joining us this
Sunday morning
[Music]